could you give
an introduction to psychedelics like a
big bold whirlwind overview
what are psychedelics what are the kinds
of psychedelics out there
in whatever way you you think uh is
meaningful
all right well when i started maps the
multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies it was very
important for me that psychedelic being
the name
and the way in which the original
meaning of psychedelic
it's mind manifesting it was created by
humphrey osmond
in dialogue with aldous huxley
and so psychedelic means mind
manifesting
and so we interpret that very broadly
to mean dreams or psychedelic anything
that kind of brings things to the
surface
holotropic breath work you know
hyperventilation is psychedelic
so most people think psychedelic is only
about certain kind of chemical
substances either natural
or synthetic but we've got a much
broader view of that
meditation can be psychedelic in some
ways but
our primary focus is on the drugs it's
on the
medicines or the you might call them
some people might call them
spiritual tools or sacraments
um there's sort of two general
categories of those
one are what are called the classic
psychedelics and those are the ego
dissolving
the sort of merged into unitive states
those are like lsd psilocybin mescaline
ayahuasca ibogaine dmt
things like that and then there's mdma
which some people even argue is not a
psychedelic
they'll say it's an m pathogen or an
intactogen it's about touching within or
empathy
it doesn't do the same kind of ego
dissolution
that the classic psychedelics do but it
brings material to the surface
in and it changes the way we process
information
and so i think you can quibble about
whether it's a
it's certainly not a classic psychedelic
but i think mdma is also a psychedelic
marijuana i would say it's a psychedelic
marijuana is closer to the classic
psychedelics than it is to
mdma one point i like to make is dreams
because then everybody can relate to
that dreams are psychedelic dreams
bring emotions feelings um
ideas concepts in symbolic form a lot of
times or just in raw motions to the
surface so
when people hear the word psychedelic
often they
are frightened by it it's about loss of
control
and it is to an extent loss of conscious
particularly with the classic
psychedelics but you know and we know
with dreams that
we can have frightening dreams
nightmares but i think that
um anchoring the the concept of
psychedelic and dreams
is really helpful for people to know
that it's kind of a natural state
and that there are other ways that you
can catalyze it than by going to sleep
and that for thousands of years
substances have been used in that way
you